vamos a tomar una función digamos una
función f que vaya de algún conjunto x a
otro conjunto y ok así de sencillo y tan
complicado puede ser porque x puede ser
cualquier conjunto déjenme dibujar
cualquier conjunto ahí tenemos un
conjunto x y por acá vamos a tener un
conjunto y digamos este es mi conjunto
ye mayúscula lo pongo bien para que se
vea que es mayúscula y nuestra función
efe es digamos una regleta de
correspondencia es un mapeo y cuando
digo un mapeo me refiero a que si yo
tomo un elemento aquí un elemento en x
digamos que éste se llame a entonces la
función f le va a asignar otro punto
aquí en y ok este otro punto que digamos
puede ser el punto b ok entonces estamos
considerando un a en el conjunto x que
después de aplicarle la función me
arroja un punto b en nuestro conjunto y
ok entonces
de esta forma estaríamos diciendo que la
función la función es es tal que a efe
aplicado a nuestro elemento a nos da
justamente el elemento b del conjunto y
ok y por supuesto esto a lo mejor es muy
abstracto y muy general pero vamos a
tratar de entender después qué pasa con
estas funciones que vayan de un espacio
rn a rm verdad y eso lo vamos a pensar
en términos de vectores hasta este
momento esto es un pequeño y breve
repaso de lo que son las funciones y a
partir de este momento voy a definir un
par de ellas voy a definir un par de
funciones la primera de ellas va a ser
la función identidad que déjenme
anotarlo aquí es la función identidad
y de hecho bueno no es que sean tan
distintas las dos funciones que voy a
definir simplemente actúan en distintos
conjuntos pero déjenme
va a empezar a decir qué es lo que
quiero decir con la función identidad y
que voy a denotar con y digamos para
para simplificar pero también voy a
decir en qué conjunto es en donde actúa
ok entonces esta es una función que va
del conjunto x en sí mismo ok es decir
si nos tomamos elementos de x me arroja
nuevamente elementos de x y qué es lo
que hace esta función por ejemplo si yo
me tomo un elemento en x entonces la
función identidad la función identidad
aplicado a nuestro elemento a es no es
otra cosa más que a mismo es decir no le
estamos haciendo exactamente nada
absolutamente nada a este elemento a es
decir si lo viéramos aquí en términos de
flechitas y de dibujitos a mi elemento a
al aplicarle la función identidad no
hace otra cosa más que escupir le el
mismo
y eso pasa con cualquier elemento si
nosotros tuviéramos por aquí otro punto
y le aplicamos la identidad sólo nos da
ese mismo punto entonces eso es el la
función identidad en el conjunto x por
supuesto también podríamos pensar en
este diagrama en otra función que sea la
función identidad por ejemplo si nos
tomamos un elemento b tomemos un
elemento b pero que se encuentra en que
cualquiera puede ser cualquiera entonces
la función identidad en nuestro conjunto
y pues simplemente al aplicarle be nos
asigna el mismo elemento b entonces
estamos pensando que esto de aquí me
toma b y le arroja el mismo después de
aplicarle la función identidad verdad
aquí estamos aplicando la función
identidad en x y acá de este lado
estamos aplicando la función identidad
pero en g muy bien entonces tú a lo
mejor podrás pensar oye pues éstas son
como funciones tontas verdad no me están
diciendo nada no están haciendo
nada interesante pero vamos a
utilizarlas mucho y en realidad es una
agradable notación que vamos a tener
para lo siguiente que quiero definir y
de hecho voy a dar una siguiente
definición que es ya realmente lo que
quiero trabajar bien en este vídeo y es
el concepto de que una función
efe es invertible ok el concepto de que
una función sea invertible y lo voy a
dar en términos de una definición es
decir fs invertible si y sólo si de
hecho a veces en algunos libros lo
denotan así como ese y muy bien entonces
efe es invertible sí solo si y lo que él
sí sólo si quiere decir es que lo que
sea que vaya a decir aquí pasa cuando f
es invertirle y f s invertible pasa
cuando esto que vaya a decir ocurre
entonces eres invertible si y sólo si
vamos a poner que existe existe
una función una función y que la boya de
notar como efe a la -1 ok
ahorita digo qué significa eso y que
además esta función va hay que definir
su dominio y su contra dominio verdad es
decir esta función toma elementos de iu
y nos arroja elementos de x es decir
mientras que f va de ekiza y la f a la
menos uno va a ir de y ax ahora qué
ocurre con esta función por qué digo
podemos pensar muchas funciones pero
esta en particular satisface o es tal
que tal qué
ocurren dos cosas la primera de ellas es
que efe ala -1 compuesta con efe
es igual a la función identidad y aquí
es en donde en donde cobra sentido tener
la función identidad de nuestro lado
verdad pero no sólo eso si nos damos
cuenta efe a la mente perdón aplicamos
primero efe entonces vamos de equis allí
y luego aplicamos efe a la menos uno que
va de iu a x entonces al final fuimos
the xx verdad entonces esto es la
función identidad en x y además debe
cumplir la otra parte que si f
está compuesta con s a la menos 1 esto
debe ser la función identidad pero en el
conjunto de mayúscula
muy bien entonces esta es la definición
de que f sea invertirle y de hecho a
esta a esta función efe a la menos 1 le
vamos a dar un nombre en especial que es
la inversa de f y ahorita voy a detallar
en por qué le decimos la inversa de f y
no una inversa de f porque es muy
distinto decir la que es hasta cierto
punto algo que la distingue de forma
única y decir una pues es porque podrían
haber varias verdad pero bueno entonces
vamos a redondear un poquito más en esto
vamos a ver en este dibujo qué significa
tener una inversa
entonces si si si tomamos f esta esta
función de aquí es la función f
ok ahora vamos a pensar en que tenemos
también una f a la menos 1 una función
efe a la menos 1 que va a ir del
conjunto y al conjunto x entonces si
tenemos una función de esta forma además
me está diciendo que si primero
aplicamos f como tenemos aquí y después
aplicamos f a la menos 1
tomemos a que nos va a dar ave ok eso es
efe lo podemos denotar así verdad
efe si después a efe a cualquiera que
sea le aplicamos efe a la menos uno es
lo que estamos diciendo en este punto de
aquí si después le aplicamos efe la
menos uno es porque estamos regresando
exactamente a verdad porque porque f
seguida de f a la menos uno es la
identidad y la identidad es haber
empezado en a y terminar en a ok esto es
efe a la menos 1 lo mismo pasa lo mismo
pasa cuando primero tomamos efe la menos
uno por ejemplo no sé que nos tomemos un
elemento aquí un elemento ye minúscula y
le aplicamos primero ésta efe ala menos
uno que digamos que ésta también es efe
a la menos uno y esto pues me da algún
punto que es ese ala menos uno del punto
i y después si le aplicamos efe lo que
nos está diciendo aquí es que si le
aplicamos efe no pueden pasar muchísimas
cosas sino que éste
se regresa exactamente allí para que así
podamos decir que la composición no hizo
otra cosa más que arrojar me el mismo
punto verdad que es la identidad muy
bien entonces sólo para redondear muy
bien estos estos diagramas
si nos damos cuenta para este primer
ejemplo
efe va de x a nuestro conjunto y esto es
f y después si aplicamos efe a la menos
uno recordemos que cuando leemos las
composiciones se ven más o menos como
como al revés verdad esta es la primera
que aplicamos y después este entonces
primero va efe y después se fue a la
menos uno entonces al final de inicio a
fin es una función que va de x en x todo
esto va de x en x por eso es que decimos
que es la identidad en x al revés si
vamos primero de x
perdón si primero aplicamos escala menos
uno que va de jett a x y luego aplicamos
f
aquí va efe y akivá efe al menos uno se
va de que a perdón de x allí entonces
todo esto fue de allí y por lo tanto si
le corresponde la identidad
en el conjunto y ok otra forma de decir
esto que es que el término o la
anotación de composición es decir efe a
la menos 1 seguida de f aplicado a
cualquier punto a aunque entonces
estamos pensando a lo mejor en este
punto a es igual a la función identidad
en el conjunto x del punto a pero eso no
es otra cosa más que a verdad la función
identidad es aquella que a cada punto le
asocia el mismo está esta anotación con
digamos con esta bolita no es otra cosa
más que efe a la menos uno aplicado a
efe de verdad
entonces esto me dice que debe ser igual
a la otra parte la otra parte me está
diciendo que f
efe si nos damos cuenta primero es efe
aplicado a efe a la menos uno de
cualquier punto y digamos ok esto debe
ser exactamente igual hay siempre que ya
sea un elemento de nuestro ye mayúscula
verdad y ya hemos visto esto en otras
ocasiones pero hay que ser mucho más
preciso porque hay que tomar ahora la
idea de invertidas cuando estamos en
conjuntos o transformaciones que
requieren matrices ok vamos a estar
trabajando en espacios de vectores
espacios vectoriales y por ello vamos a
trabajar con matrices entonces es bueno
recordar este concepto de invertibilidad
para cuando vayamos a utilizarlo en
espacios vectoriales y ahora
una pregunta que podrías ahorita estarte
planteando es bueno nosotros podríamos
tener una función invertible lo primero
es que no sabemos en qué situar en qué
situaciones
efe es invertible pero bueno vamos a
suponer que tenemos una función que es
invertible que tenemos nuestra función
invertible y la pregunta casi inmediata
que siempre tenemos es bueno como éste
es invertible tenemos una función
efe a la menos uno pero cuántas
funciones de éstas podemos tener es
decir la pregunta es es la inversa de f
única o pueden haber varias inversas ok
entonces vamos a tratar de responder
esta pregunta qué pasaría si nosotros
nosotros nos tomamos dos inversas
digamos supongamos que tenemos aquí una
función g que vaya de nx es decir voy a
suponer que es una inversa verdad
entonces primero va de la equis y además
sabemos que g
kg
seguida de efe ok que es esta parte es
igual a la identidad en x y también
sabríamos que f seguida de g efe
seguida de g es igual a la identidad
pero en g aunque esto es suponer que
tenemos que una inversa aquí estamos
diciendo que que es una inversa hasta
ahorita podemos decir una verdad una
inversa
una inversa de f
y vamos a suponer que tenemos otra es
decir vamos a suponer que existe una h
ok digamos
h que vaya de nuestro espacio con
nuestro conjunto y al espacio o al
conjunto x que cumple esta misma
propiedad que el h perdón seguida de f
no es otra cosa más que la identidad de
nx y que también h seguida de g
de perdón al revés verdad ahora tenemos
efe efe seguida de h es igual a la
identidad pero en ok esto es pensar que
h es otra inversa otra inversa
si tenemos nosotros dos si tenemos
nosotros dos inversas distintas digamos
g y h lo que vamos a ver es que en
realidad no pueden ser distintas que en
realidad son las mismas y como ya el
dibujo de arriba quedó muy encimado
vamos a hacer otro digamos que aquí
tengo mi conjunto x y de este otro lado
tengo mi conjunto y así de grandes vamos
a pintarlos entonces
tenemos nuestra función f que a cada
punto digamos este punto de aquí le
asocia algún otro punto de acá que esta
es nuestra función
efe y de esa partimos suponiendo que es
invertible entonces sabemos que al menos
existe una función de hecho estamos
suponiendo que hay dos digamos que a
cada punto al aplicarle f y luego
aplicarle una g ok esto es que esto es
este punto de aquí arriba ok este punto
de acá arriba me dice primero aplica f
sale ya nos fuimos por efe luego aplica
g entonces eso fue la identidad ok eso
no es otra cosa más que pensar en la
identidad la identidad en el conjunto x
también tenemos una función h que si
aplicamos f
y luego aplicamos h regresamos a este
punto original entonces aquí tenemos
nuestra función h
y bueno tenemos la otra propiedad que ya
nada más voy a poner muy breve que si
tenemos primero si aplicamos primero una
g ok la función g y luego aplicamos la
función f entonces regresamos al mismo
punto a través de las identidades verdad
simple si primero aplicamos g
y luego aplicamos efe en espéreme lage
va en este en esta dirección si no va
acá verdad por kg que dijimos que va de
la equis entonces si tenemos una g que
va de iu a x y luego aplicamos efe que
la f va de ekiza y entonces si vamos
después por efe hasta este punto
entonces regresamos esencialmente a la
identidad pero en ok lo mismo pasa con
la h pero con esto con esto me voy a
quedar entonces recordemos quienes g o
más bien una forma de expresar de
expresar que es como la identidad en x
seguida de g verdad porque si tenemos
una g por ejemplo aquí tenemos aplicando
g y después le aplicamos la identidad
pues en realidad no cambie el resultado
verdad simplemente llegué a este punto
rojito y al aplicarle la identidad
llegue al mismo punto rojito entonces no
hay mayor complicación de hecho si quien
podemos hacerlo en un dibujo más grande
aquí tenemos x aquí tenemos
y entonces se aplicó primero que como
dice y luego la identidad llegue a este
punto y luego la identidad sigo en ese
mismo punto entonces no hay ninguna
complicación con escribir ag de esa
forma pero la identidad podemos expresar
lo que de otra manera verdad porque la
identidad puede ser aplicar h
nos más bien sería aplicar efe
primero aplicamos efe y luego aplicamos
h verdad
empezamos en este punto llegamos aquí y
luego h que fue exactamente lo mismo que
aplicar la identidad entonces esto lo
podemos reescribir como h seguida de f
verdad es primero aplicar f y luego h es
la identidad y luego aplicar g pero ya
he demostrado hace en algún otro vídeo
no recuerdo exactamente cuál que la
composición de funciones es asociativa
entonces podemos cambiar estos
paréntesis como h seguida de fcc vida de
g verdad de esta forma podemos asociar y
esto quien es esto es
seguida de quién es efe aplicado después
de que entonces aplicamos que es justo
este dibujito que hice aquí pero lo
podemos hacer nuevamente esto es x esto
es ya y entonces primero aplicamos g que
va de la x esto es que muy bien y luego
aplicamos
efe entonces si aplicamos efe después
estamos regresando a este punto verdad
que no es otra cosa más que la identidad
en ok entonces esto es la identidad en
ye y que si tenemos esto pues no es otra
cosa más que h verdad esto es h porque
ahora sí tenemos una una función de la
identidad por ejemplo aquí aquí tenemos
la identidad y después aplicamos h pues
no cambia el resultado de verdad porque
parto de este punto regreso a este punto
y después me voy por h entonces sí es
cierto que esto es h
aquí y a qué conclusión llegue kg sí
suponíamos la existencia de dos pues en
realidad son las mismas verdad así que
toda función invertible tiene una única
inversa si supones dos entonces no
pueden ser dos en realidad son las
mismas verdad aún no sabemos qué es lo
que causa que una función sea invertible
pero lo que sí sabemos ya es que su
inversa debe ser única